hello everyone David and Karen of film
courage here with us today are the
husband and wife powerhouse team behind
joke productions Joe fancy own and
biagio messina together they are
crowdfunding for the incredible
documentary dying to do Letterman about
Steve reason who learns that he has
incurable liver cancer dedicating his
life to living a stream performing
stand-up comedy on the late show with
david letterman now the documentary
dying to do Letterman follows Steve's
incredible often heartbreaking and
ultimately uplifting five year journey
Steve's advice to everyone is live your
dream or die trying so thank you joke
and Biagio hello yeah oh thank you it's
so great to be here with you again and I
just want to say for the record we
attribute a lot of the success we've
been having with the movie and with the
campaign to our appearance on your show
you guys got the golden touch thank you
for finding us and following us on
Twitter and telling people about us but
you are a very high on our list of
thanks and I think you already know but
you know you're one of the very special
people that have a special thanks in the
credits of the movie now and it was our
honor to give that to you because you've
done so much for the indie film
community and thank you for being
awesome oh thank you very much well when
that's Wow yeah that's that's quite way
to begin it's really tremendous with
what you two are putting in you know I
we have seen some some sort of film
courage peeps but there's a lot a lot
more than a joke and Biagio and Steve
Maison and Denise Maison peeps and it's
wonderful to see it all come together
thank you so so first off you guys were
we're doing a live stream one of the
latest live streams we've seen you like
1130 or something like that last night
how stupid for movies yeah it's late
very late yeah we all that time ah how
wait were you guys up last night I don't
think we got onto like what yeah yeah
they were the schedule is right around
the corner yeah you know that's that
show it's produced from streaming garage
mike rotman uh you know it's a
guy we met on Twitter um he was on the
front cover of Video Maker magazine last
month and he actually streams these live
productions from his garage true in
these spirits and stupid for movies has
quite a following I and we were he's had
like Colin Hanks on there and you know
it all sorts of people that are far more
by you know important than us and so we
were just so thrilled when he asked us
to be on and it was the harry potter
episode so i think it had it's already
had something like thirty eight thousand
views it's crazy his own yeah it was a
pretty popular on a son yeah it was a
lot of fun very cool we know the two of
you are extremely busy right now um
you're in the middle of a 60-day
crowdfunding campaign i'm already well
blowing through the 37,000 mogul yeah
yes well when we spoke to you a couple
months ago outside the film courage
studio after our radio interview you
told us about this dream of trying to
get dying to do Letterman nominated for
an Oscar so tell us about the dream and
tell us how docu weeks answered this
prayer Wow do you want to take this one
honey sure well you know the oh word as
we're calling it there we go ahead good
mentioned a few times by some audience
members that we've seen in our in our
festival going center screenings and
well you know tremendously flattering I
think what a lot of people don't
understand is that it's quite the
process to even qualify before you can
even get nominated it's not like they
just pick a couple people and they're
like okay you're nominated you have to
submit to qualify and that includes a
one-week theatrical run in LA and one
week at home run in New York and that's
quite expensive and so you know what our
plan had been you know let's do a slow
rollout we'll build our audience flow
lane we'll just do the festival circuit
this year and we'll think about the oh
word next year well I'm part of our
submissions had been document without a
box just like a lot of the festivals and
it's a hundred dollars and we're just
like oh whatever let's try it will take
a shot what doc you exist for those of
you who don't know it's run by the
International Documentary Association
it's sort of the most prestigious way
for a documentary to qualify because
every
here the invite less than 20 films and
past documentaries to come out of doc
you weeks in court include born into
brothels taxing to the dark side Jesus
camp last years wasteland as 17 Oscar
winners and nominees over the last 10
years so it's like we thought well never
we're never gonna get in so we figured
no way we're winning the lottery but you
can't win unless you play so we
submitted and then kind of forgot about
it and then all of a sudden we got a
phone call we were actually in chicago
for the just for laughs festival when um
we got this nice phone call saying you
know you're in and we're like wow I'm so
excited I think bra sums it up pretty
well I was I was I was screaming louder
than that that's my place for nearly a
week I just because I I've already a
loud talker I was a loud scream or like
for seven days after we heard we were
inoculating so right and so what done
with the ID a dust through the program
that they have called documents is they
make the cost of you know having your
one week theatrical in New York into one
week in LA and you have to have certain
advertisements with that and you have to
have certain press stuff that happens
during that time it's all very detailed
and technical and there's a whole
checklist and and the ID a helps us get
through that process and reduces the
cost tremendously because they take
these 17 films this year and kind of
help spread the costs across the board
and they're able to make deals that we
wouldn't be able to make and all that
kind of stuff so they help independent
filmmakers qualify and so while there's
still a you know a big cost to us it is
you know less than half of what it would
have been without the ID a so yeah and
also it doesn't mean it's the prestige
factor like again we never thought we
would be able to be mentioned alongside
names of films like those you know I
mean when you hear about these huge
documentaries that they come out and
obviously we thought we kind of thought
the documentary world just didn't like
us you know I mean we were told by a lot
of people who've seen the doc you know
you really should take it on the health
care system or you should have you know
gone deeper with you know that you know
the world of cancer and we're like but
that wasn't Steve's journey like he what
we were never following the story about
a man trying to change the system or a
man whose life was really affected one
way or the other by the fact that the
health care system is the way it is he
was a guy chasing this dream so we
thought well is that
really the way it is and the doc were
like are we really going to be just you
know like toefl you had a real
documentary you don't take out an issue
if you look at the last couple of years
of documentaries a lot of the big ones
have been kind of policy documentaries
that are looking to either change policy
or to influence policy or to bring
attention to a bad policy that needs to
change and so I think that you know we
ran into some of those reactions were
like well you're not that you're just an
entertaining little movie and that's not
quite what we think of as documentary
but in the International Documentary
sociation you know to their credit you
know they've come out this year and said
you know we want documentaries there's
all kinds of documentaries not there is
there's a lot of ones and documentaries
and Diodati weeks is shared so many
different kinds and it made me so happy
because I mean go yes there really is
acceptance for all kinds of Doc's this
year and I just I'm so proud of
documents and you know after not getting
into some of the bigger festivals early
on we thought well this is going to be
an uphill battle but this is really turn
the tide and scared the hell out of us
so the helping cat I really kicked us in
the bus we had to crank things up
because you know it's not the easy to
chase them chase an Oscar it's very
expensive than very difficult what was
your plan B if you had not gotten into
doc you weeks what would have happened
well yeah that was that that was it was
playing eggs we thought we weren't gonna
get it yeah I mean plan B what was
exactly plan a and it was just doing a
slow roll out it was building our
audience through you know screenings
festival screenings meeting with people
Twitter getting the word out you know
building our mailing list building
everything and then depending on how you
know how we were able to roll it out but
you know we were going to reevaluate in
the spring of 2012 to say okay are we
going to do an Oscar run because it's a
lot of money or we just you know going
to do a few thiet racal screenings
ourselves like in cleveland or Chicago
you know where we know we can get some
people because geologists from Cleveland
and cease from Chicago and those kind of
things and then just you know do to DVD
and we've had interest already from
distributors for you know the DVD and
the digital world
louts so it's you know the only thing
that's kind of been going is this idea
this dream of getting into theaters and
getting it to people and we did have to
two offers for small theatrical
distribution but the offers were so it
was so early on in the process of the
film and they wanted that you know they
wanted to own so much of it and on so
much of Steve that it just wasn't worth
it you know the we would have asked
control yeah it would have completely
lost control were like why do we put six
years of our life into this movie to
hand it over after one month to somebody
who may put it on a shelf or can you
know the contracts is they can do
whatever they want with it so all the
way along you know obviously from
following you guys film courage we I
think we actually learned about
Kickstarter because of you guys and we
funded some terrific campaigns over the
last year and a half that we've heard
about through you and others you know
Julie Jessica and fill with tilt
obviously Lucas McNally is here without
rent Gary Gary King is heads you know
that without I always screw up the title
is it so live but how do you write a Joe
sure of in shock that I probably still
got a wrought-iron pologize here any
right to plug this out I did fund it
just can't pronounce it um you know and
we really love the Kickstarter community
and we always thought well could you
really like launched a Kickstarter
campaign to put a movie in theaters like
could you say look we finished the movie
now you help us get into theaters and
that was what our plan was for 2012 and
then documents it and really a week in
New York in a week in Los Angeles is one
heck of a way to kick off at the actual
run I mean you really can't start bigger
than that so we said okay this is the
time we were really scared joke will
tell you we didn't sleep for a week
trying to figure out how to do this
Kickstarter campaign we read every
article we could possibly find um you
know we just and we're still learning
every day we're reading more about how
to keep it going and we thought well we
hope maybe we make three or four
thousand our first week and we made ten
thousand our first day you know 20,000
in the first 48 hours and as we close up
week one we were at 40,000 and over 400
backers and we are so grateful and
people have already seen me cry so I
won't do it again but we're it's just I
mean just bawling and could not believe
the incredible support has come out and
really with practically no press we had
a really nice indiewire article that
came out we were on the front page of
indieWIRE but that was really after we'd
already broke
30 thousand so I mean it was just just
love and support from people we met on
your show we met on Twitter on Facebook
CS little circuit on the festival
circuit like just coming through we have
seven weeks to go so we're shooting for
the moon right now you know I think
we've told you guys we love John Reese
in his book think outside the box office
and so right now our goal is to raise
enough money in the next seven weeks to
actually follow the plan in John races
book and do a small theatrical rollout
coast to coast and yeah that's what's
going on ok let's go into more detail on
some of these on some of these topics
and issues and bring it up here you know
first i'm going back to before you you
know going back to the sleepless nights
before you launch this campaign you know
you two are probably busier than any
other two or any other do all we can
think of aren't you guys too busy to
take on something like this yes and that
was a huge kind of conversation we've
had is part of our quote unquote plan B
you know that we were just going to wait
till next year was um we knew that if we
wanted to do qualify for an Oscar this
year we had to do it by I think the end
of August our sep tember or something
you know whatever we check the academy
rules it was then and Stephen Denise and
I SAT together we're like we're all so
busy to summer we just don't have time
to do it so let's just keep going with
the small roll out and you know
gathering steam and hopefully by the
spring you know we'll have more time and
we'll have a bigger database and we'll
just go bananas on it well then doc you
weeks happen so we're like well we have
to make it work now this is a
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity and it's
been pretty crazy Steve's been out
traveling and you know performing
stand-up comedy um Denise just had a big
open house at her studio so she's been
busy planning that and you know we
obviously have the shows that are
currently going so it's been some long
long days and long nights um but we've
all credit to joke she's being modest
she's pretty much taken the brunt of the
shows you know working at commercial
kings on IFC right now which is fridays
at 10 we're still wrapping that up and
we're shooting caged our new documentary
series for MTV and again these aren't
like huge ginormous budgets these are
still very tight and usually that would
take all over time so John can somehow
managed to juggle those well I've you
know really
to launch the Kickstarter campaign you
know I mean we've done both together but
I've taken the brunt she's had to be
without me um Steve gets back later
tonight so he's going to start running
now the kickstarter campaign probably
for the next week we'll still obviously
be a part of it and be popping up and
you know putting off as much time as we
can into it but we've gotten to the
point where we've almost sort of you
know broken things over here and so we
need to think we need to fix that and
but it's worth it you know I mean listen
you at the end of the day between 50 and
100 documentaries will qualify for an
Oscar this year and they have a 100 shot
you know even though that's still long
odds that's to me that's the
once-in-a-lifetime you know odds I mean
at the end a day like we can't complain
right we hit our goal in a week so if we
didn't sleep for that week and I felt
like I was addicted to some kind of drug
constantly like refresh refresh but um
you know now it's like okay great now we
can kind of let Steve take the second
roll out with this and really have you
know it's good we're a team there's four
of us so to be able to hand things off
when need be helps align it was hard
with just two and so now I feel like
we're so thankful to our immediate
network obviously twit anyone who's been
following us on twitter has seen a flood
of tweets and we're dialing back i knows
now you know our goal now is to we have
some interesting plans for the next two
phases of the of the kickstarter
campaign so so going back to the
research that you did you said you read
some articles about various successful
campaigns take us through kind of the
science that you went through like did
you actually kind of chart and look at
at what point they hit a certain amount
i mean was there was there all that kind
of focused research in it or did you
just kind of watch videos and glanced at
things ya know it was pretty focused we
we very carefully allied i did i read
through as many analyses of other
campaigns as I could because we wanted
to do it right you know to me this had
to be a win-win for everybody not just
for us not just for Steve but also for
the people that were kind enough to
support us like I wanted to make sure
that they were going to feel like by
supporting it weren't just all we're
going to help the movie but they were
going to get something back to I really
wanted it to feel like a like hey we're
all in this together and so it was sort
of number one figuring out from a big
picture how to achieve that and number
to you know just like little tips and
tricks to make sure your campaign to pop
right so so for instance some of the
things I followed very very carefully a
lot of campaigns don't have a one dollar
prize they don't have a ten dollar prize
you know um and so I want a reward and
calling the prizes I haven't slept but a
reward and so I wanted to make sure that
anybody who wanted to pledge could
pledge a dollar and get something and
because of the unique you know the
unique aspect of this movie would Steve
being a stand-up comedian being able to
give you know an mp3 for a dollar is
what you would buy it for an itunes
about you know and for ten dollars be
able to get an entire album of every
joke he sent a letterman we thought
those seems like unique rewards that
people might respond to you know it
would not have to pay a lot of money to
um so that so that was some advice we
follow a lot of campaigns that have
failed started like at 25 or 50 dollars
and have no lower ones um you know
another thing that we had read was don't
assume that the people who come to your
Kickstarter site know what Kickstarter
is and I thought that was great advice
because most of the people who've seen
us at festivals a lot of them are over
60 and have never even you know barely
use their email much less visit a site
like Kickstarter you know and just a lot
of other people who haven't heard of it
so i'll be in crafting the text for the
page why they make sure that we tried to
give a really easy explanation on the
page of how to you know how to succeed
you know how to use Kickstarter or what
it was another big piece of advice you
see everywhere and it was something we
put a lot of time into was really work
hard on your video and put yourself in
your video you know and so and Steve
actually didn't want to be in the video
believe it or not and I was like you are
going in this video I am NOT doing the
video asking for support and not putting
you in it and he just thought well
doesn't it seem weird like when people
like think like oh I you know he's I'm
like no no you need to be in the video
so um and within the video applying the
same things letting people know um that
the movie had already had some success
what's known as social proof as we've
read in a few different sites so so
including you know some critical reviews
and the standing ovation was important
to let people know they're that people
were already giving the movie at stamp
of approval another thing that was very
important what the video was not to go
too long and sherry can they're actually
watched the rough
of our nine minute version of the video
and thank God said cut that thing in
half probably the best move we made some
other advice we took we actually took
not from Kickstarter specific advice but
just from like web you know web surfing
advice in general one of the things that
I see a lot of Kickstarter campaigns do
is there's so many links on the page to
take you off the page you know like
click here to learn more about the movie
and it goes to the site or click here to
see a video and it goes to youtube and
one of the great things about
Kickstarter is that you can post these
daily updates that work like a blog so
any single time we wanted to give more
information that we couldn't fit on that
front page we tried to write as an
update on Kickstarter that way when
people click over to learn more you know
people get distracted they mean to
donate but they get dragged off
something happens I wanted to make sure
they still have the opportunity to
pledge while learning more about the
movie so I tried to make everything
linked to a post on the Kickstarter page
itself so you can learn more without
having to go away or surf away and
remember to come back later and I think
that's turned out pretty well too um
another thing I by the way am i boring
you guys I'm just going off that's like
so much more like stuff from what you're
telling you're making a yen for us okay
um you know another thing that was
really important you know as regular
updates and I think the one thing that
we have not failed at so far and
everyone say failed it's a big word I
think we found one things that we're
trying to do and we hope to do more that
we did early is to have separate updates
14 backers and one is for backers only
so we have an interview that we shot
early on and part 1 anybody could see
and in part two is for backers only so
anybody who pledged at least a dollar
could see the rest of the interview and
we actually have four more interviews
already shot that we're editing right
now whether it be part one will be for
everyone in part two will be for backers
only that way people who are backers get
a little extra added value for having
believed in us and trusted us and people
who aren't if they're interested in the
project and they give as little as one
dollar they can see exclusive content
that you can't see anywhere else so I
think that having that for backers only
part two early on I think that helped a
lot with getting more people in and we
just got so busy we just couldn't finish
the videos so we have a lot more of
those
coming in weeks two three and four of
our campaign and so that's like a little
handful of tips i'm planning on putting
out a whole list of everything we
learned soon but i think those were the
big ones and i think i've talked for
like five minutes after he was studying
so much and so hard for this that it
ended up being where he was getting like
conflicting advice and then he'd come to
me and we talked about it and we had
long conversations about you know um
what so what what number to pick and you
know what what is our goal because we're
like well even if we get half of what
it's going to cost and that'll help and
then people were like no ask for more
and that was scary because if you don't
make it you don't get it so we're like a
horse yeah that was a big big
conversation in 30 days for 60 days was
huge you know everyone says 30 days but
we have so much press lined up for you
know the end of august and beginning of
sep tember because of dr. week so we're
like well do we use that press to help
get more money to get the movie into
theaters everywhere um it was I mean you
know who knows if that's the right
decision or not only time will tell but
it's just been it's you know it's scary
it's very scary it is i will say in the
numbers that was a big thing right
because we knew we personally we knew
credit cards you know getting through
docu weeks was gonna be up around 37,000
and so we were originally going to ask
for 17 um because we thought well you
know we're ready putting her on money in
and but the fact of the matter is we
weren't going to be able to do the movie
justice at dr weeks with 17 and even
with our credit cards really cost more
than that because you have to get a
special print made that the Academy
improves and we need to take special ads
out and we need to have I mean travel
the street team so we knew that we
wanted to do it right um and and so we
thought well let's ask for 37 but
explain in our video and it's one thing
you see a lot of campaigns what they do
is they hit their goal right early on so
the kevin has been lucky and then all of
a sudden they have to rejigger their
whole campaign because they're like what
we asked for this but we really need
this and you know and i think sometimes
people think it's a little disingenuous
it's not just people are excited because
they reach their goal and so what we
wanted to do is one address desperate
right up front and so from the very
beginning and putting together our video
we wanted to explain listen well all
we're asking for is 37 because that's
the bare minimum we need to get the
donkey weeks our hope is the far
surpassed that because every dollar we
raise over that means the movie comes to
even more theaters so and we just
thought that if we were honest with
people and just said that and that's in
a Kickstarter you know you get it all or
nothing and so we're asking for the bare
minimum but we're hoping we make more we
thought that people would tune in with
that and like she really summed it up
with the length of days man everybody's
like 30 days is that is the sweet spot
don't go past 30 days we got one if we
get lucky and we have a good start a
good week one and all this momentum
builds why do we want the campaign died
in 30 days with 30 days of us being in
front of audiences you know doing all
kinds of press I mean anybody who goes
to the website sees the Kickstarter
video so why throw that away if we get
lucky so that was the one piece of
advice that almost universally says
don't go long and we ignored it so we'll
see how that we'll see how that works I
mean so far it's worked out okay oh yeah
well yeah you know what it sounds like I
mean I mean if you have a week like you
two have had then you really can't go
wrong I don't think you know what is
unless you urgently needed the money if
you need the money right away then it's
stretching out and you're not able to
access the money but in this case you
know you guys have certainly one out
well that was the gamble because it was
like if we didn't make our goal and then
you know we're flowing everything on our
credit cards till we get the money and
it doesn't come in I mean the campaign
doesn't end until doc Ewing starts you
know and so it's it was a huge gamble
but it was a gamble but here's a big
it's like it's like Monday morning
quarterbacking you look at the last week
we had and you're like well we should
have gone 30 days dog but essentially we
had zero clue I mean we were hoping for
two thousand dollars at first week we
could have been never in her wildest
dreams thought we were gonna hit 40 ever
you know I mean ever it's it's just been
mind-blowing so you know it's like when
we didn't know what I'm not we were
gonna make two thousand dollars the
first week we're like well we may need
that 60 days we may need that press at
the end just even make our goal so you
know it wasn't just so we can you know
go above and beyond and get to a hundred
thousand and put
moving theaters everywhere it was just
like can we get to 37 so we were really
you know we were thinking like we'll be
at docu weeks going you know I know you
just paid for your ticket but you mind
giving us some money because otherwise
you know we're gonna pay for ya lo see
our movie let us tell you what
Kickstarter is no before we start this
Q&A so the fact that we've been so
tremendously blessed in this last week
you know it now is easy to go back and
be like what were you thinking yet you
know we were thinking it wasn't going to
happen I can't say it enough times thank
you thank you thank you film courage
thank you everybody and I'll say it ten
times or just interview I never want you
to think that we don't know how lucky we
are how to be accepted by the community
like this we know and we are grateful
and we're gonna spend the rest of our
life giving back to this community
everywhere we possibly can well you know
and on the other end of that spectrum
you guys have made it look too easy you
know not now now there's gonna be people
that are gonna see what you've done and
they're gonna be like you know what I
know I can go out and raise fifty
thousand i know i can raise sixty
thousand a hundred thousand because of
because of how easy you guys have made
it look I have some tips for those
people it's not easy and i will say like
while it was never my intention when we
started blogging two years or three
years ago whatever it was to necessarily
start a kickstarter campaign we knew
that we wanted to support the community
because we knew someday we were going to
need the community to support us and so
we started the blog with the hope of
providing valuable information the
people you know we we started and that
was really all we could give but we
started twitter with the hope of being
able to give something to people and
then when we saw the kickstarter and
indiegogo we funded projects on both we
sort of discovered what those were we
tried to support those things not just
because someday we might do it but
because if you want to be part of a
community its give and take you know and
so it wasn't like oh we better fund them
because we're going to need them this
fund us later it was like maybe someday
when we need to ask the community will
remember that we helped and if they
don't that's okay too because we're here
to contribute and so i really believe
that two years we spent meeting people
like you on twitter and facebook and
blogging and that you know depth that i
think that that's why we had the success
we did and I'm so proud of that and I
hope that that means that we have been
able to provide
a little value and you know and we're
going to keep doing that you know as
much as we can in the years to come even
if we never run number Kickstarter so
program again ourselves we are going to
keep supporting Kickstarter and where to
keep supporting IndieGoGo and we're
going to keep running blog post and keep
sharing because that's what being part
of the communities about but I think
another big part of you know why it's
been so successful is because you know
the community is fantastic and you guys
have come out in droves and thank you so
much but we also went to the people in
our lives and our work and our friends
and like we said like the people we met
at festival screenings who aren't part
of this community you have no idea what
Kickstarter's who knew nothing and you
know ask them um show them our passion
said you know here's what we're doing
any way you can help and then like kind
of walk them through the process at
times you know people were like what's
an amazon account and where do I go from
here and you know reaching out and
listen it's very hard to ask people you
know hey can't can you give me at all it
can you give me five dollars but um if
you believe in what you're selling if
you believe if you have the passion if
you if it's just in your DNA that this
is the project then you know you you
know you're you're not asking for money
you're asking for people to join the
ride and you're asking for people to
come on this journey with you and what
kickstart allows us to do by giving
rewards you know it doesn't feel like
we're just you know I just I just it
doesn't feel like just taking it feels
like we're just building a team and
building you know this amazing kind of
dying do Letterman world that's just
really that's just kind of exciting and
fun but you have to be willing to do
that you have to be willing to go out
there and it kind of put yourself in a
vulnerable position because you're
asking and people may say no and
sometimes people don't want to you know
so they don't ask but I think what we've
proven is if you don't ask you don't get
it so we have been very specific about
what we're asking for I mean we say over
and over again please pledge now I mean
it I think you just have to get past
yourself in like nobody wants to ask for
it for money or help but in the back of
her head we're always like look we're
doing this for Steve this is the one
shot we have at getting his life story
in the theaters we there can't be any
ego here they can't be any oh I'm
too proud to ask for your help like we
just have to put that aside I don't care
what people think about us and we're
gonna ask everybody and we're gonna say
this is why we're asking and also let's
be honest I mean I think that Steve
story is a big part of why people
responded to the campaign you know I
think that if I was doing a little
action thriller right now I don't know
that would have raised this kind of
money you know in one week and we're
very very aware of that and people have
also responded to the fact that we've
been working on this project for six
years and we put lots of money and
energy and time into it it's not you
know we're not going like you know I
kind of want to try something you want
to pay for it he knows that's not what
our Kickstarter campaign is our
Kickstarter campaign is very much like
here's where we are we've done
everything we love nothing more than for
it for you to be able to enjoy our work
you know will you help us you know get
it to a theater near you yeah I think
that that attitude you every meeting
we've ever had in Hollywood where we've
gone in and they don't know who we are
you know we always say to them look you
shouldn't take a chance on us if we're
not willing to take a chance on
ourselves and here's all the stuff we've
produced on our own die there you go
this is us putting our money where our
mouth is and I feel like people respond
to that because if you're if you're
willing to put your money where your
mouth is the people go okay well but if
you're not well why why why should they
take a chance on you and I think that
the community Oh Stevens never responded
to the fact that we did wait to the
movie was done and you know and we were
receiving accolades before we ever asked
for any help because we wanted people to
feel good about their about their
investment in ennis in the movie and
about what they were getting so so who
do you have on your team helping you
push this campaign it just can't be the
two of you is it I mean I don't know
well earlier that joke was handling some
of the shows and that you were sort of
at the helm doing the Twitter there's no
one else oh well well I we've had a
little bit of help from my sister oh
yeah my sister Gina she popped up in one
of the update videos and she's been
working really hard to reach out to the
cancer community um and that's a little
bit slower slower going but she's
planning big seeds you know and she's
you know she's really kind of team yeah
she put us in contact with team Lucy who
I don't know if you guys saw that update
but on Team Lucy they sent us a video
about how they discovered the movie and
they loved it so much and Lucy as a
young I think she's seven
she's young she's been 25 and somehow
know her exact date but she has leukemia
and so we got this thing we're like this
is amazing you know I couldn't believe
that they came over and supported us so
when we found out we made our goal that
next morning we announced the benefit
screening with all proceeds going to
team Lucy we're organizing that right
now we're going to have the date soon
but we are putting up a screening and
every single pain that comes in is going
to go to Lucy's medical bills or toys or
whatever she wants yeah we're maybe a
kind of a big event because the family's
gotten some stuff donated to them that
we can silent auction and so Steve's
going to be there and we're still
putting out to details but worst part
you know stand up and part movie and
we're looking for other people you know
to come on board in terms of you know
food and you know beverage and that kind
of stuff but it's going to be an awesome
kind of you know fundraising event for
her yeah yeah and we're glad that we can
do it for you know another great aspect
of what you two are doing with this
campaign something that we love you not
only have the incentives the rewards
that come along the side on top of that
you're giving extras you're giving
things away for free to kind of get
people involved get people interested
why why why why are you doing this haha
you know I epical bribes I don't know I
i would say that in in this time that
you know when we were nobodies out of
you know college to where we are now
there have been people along the way who
helped us who gave us some things for
free who are like you know what here you
know do this to get started I believe in
you I believe you're talented just go
for it and I think it's one of those
things where you know um it's just it's
not it's it's just it's just a nice
thing to do and it you know if it helps
people then great and if it gets people
to decide awesome if not that's okay you
know it's just something that you know
we have it it's sitting here um you know
what are we going to do patent it no you
know let's share it yeah I was really
proud I made this little you know silly
little Kickstarter graphic with like the
green bar you know sliding up and it
took me the better part of
I was like you know what I just think a
lot of other people might like to use
this or stick it in their own project so
I just that was one of the things we
made available is you know free free
graphics for your Kickstarter project
and you know because again like she said
it's not like why should just sit here
on a server and do no good and you know
even if people don't contribute to the
campaign you know even if they just go
because anyone can download the graphic
you know I mean it's great because we're
giving back but they're also going to
hear about the movie so I think it's
again it's win-win for everybody we want
everybody to feel like they came out
ahead I never want anybody to feel like
you know we got something over on that
vice versa and again one of my regrets
Anna was believed in a week i was i was
hoping to give back even more you know
we're trying to I'm trying to put
together some more graphics packages and
amla I had this idea about doing a free
well it's not going to happen a free
iPhone app but that's that's that I'm
getting crazy now but but we are we are
trying to have a lot more things to give
back to the community over the next you
know the the next seven weeks and
tonight we're going to do a little live
you know Q&A I think you guys know
tonight at six o'clock we just figured
out how to hook it Anna justin.tv and
anybody has any questions about anything
doesn't have to be about the campaign it
can be about working in Hollywood or why
the heck she married me or I don't know
anything they want to know if Teddy
brewing questions we're going to be here
from at least six until seven bsd at
least 9 into 10 EST and we're just going
to answer questions from people it's not
an advertisement for the kickstarter
campaign it's not a telephone it's
nothing except we're giving you an hour
and whenever you guys want it's all for
you that's that's what we're doing
tonight very cool nice well let's talk
about how launching this campaign has
increased your social media awareness
have you noticed more followers on your
Twitter and and more Facebook friends to
your fan page I don't how boy is not so
bad I don't know we haven't had time to
check you know and i will say i think we
probably got some more followers and i
think i probably scared some followers
away because you all know we've had a
few heavy campaign days and uh you know
bridging forty thousand dollars and four
hundred followers in one week was not
easy and and again it meant i was having
the be shameless and I hate to flood the
tweet stream i hate the flood the
facebook but we're doing it for our
friend and you know and i felt you know
if people decide to unfollow us I
understand because we're asking for a
lot
um so I'll i think we've gained a lot of
followers we probably have lost a few
too and i'm looking forward to checking
that i will say going on stupid for
movies was really awesome because they
just had Collin Hanks on and so it's
like oh my gosh you know we're doing
Collin Hanks but it's nice to be sitting
in the same seeds you know uh so I
obviously the indiewire I mean you know
us as filmmakers I think obviously we've
been noticed more for stuff like
commercial kings and scream queens and
caged which we're very proud of but it's
not you know that's a very separate
world than the indie film world which is
what we started in we started as indie
filmmakers so to finally be in indy wire
and have them refer to us as joke to
biagio and refer to the movie and write
such a glowing review of the kickstarter
campaign it was just I felt like that
was the first time the filmmaker
community at large maybe got to meet us
and it was such a nice way to meet
everybody I think it was also kind of I
mean the indie Wired magazine it was
just amazing we were just floored and I
think part of what's funny about it the
behind the scenes is they make it seem
like we knew exactly what yeah you like
this brilliantly designed campaign
agonize over every detail and we didn't
know it's you know again in some Monday
morning quarterbacking it's like now
looking back going oh yeah I guess that
worked really well but Louise when we
launched at the moment we like hit that
button we just looked at each other more
likes your ego and you were our first
date Don't courage our very first
backers back number one record number
one film courage it was so great I was
so excited and remember we couldn't
believe it because like in the first
hour we raised like two hundred dollars
we put up this video we were going crazy
we're so excited two hundred dollars in
an hour this is something amazing and
then by the end of the day we're at
10,000 inches in shock um but yeah yeah
it's been it's been pretty amazing well
I'm curious who are some of these people
backing the campaign are these strangers
are these people that you've interacted
with on your email list oh hey ray it's
very funny because we have we personally
sent out about six hundred emails to
friends family and business associates
people we've worked with over the years
we haven't talked to him in 10 years
yeah
seriously it was like people we worked
with or at least if I recognize their
name i put it up close i dint recognize
her name I was like okay I can't send
this email um and then you know so it's
very funny like going through our
backers list it's like there's clearly
to Twitter community and it's clearly a
bunch of people who heard about it on
Facebook and nowhere else and then you
know it's like okay well here's
everybody that I emailed you know not
everybody came and donated but you know
a big chunk of them and you know we're
like okay well there's all the maisons
you can see it in their last name and so
you know it's been really kind of an
amazing thing in terms of you know o our
mailing list died a new letter and
mailing lists that we build at festivals
and staffing and honestly I think that
is I have to seem the least return
because I had trouble I tried to send a
play a text email with with MailChimp
and ran into a lot of trouble and I got
all these emails back send links not
working so we're gonna send out a new
email with MailChimp using HTML instead
of just plain text and see if we can
format the links better oh but so
whatever eyes yeah probably it's been
amazing it's been kind of all over you
know from everybody and actually Stephen
the knees because they've been so busy
this last week with their own step they
haven't even really hit their whole
friends and family and you know people
from their past so um you know we're
hoping that you know they can start
rolling into that in the next couple of
weeks yeah which is great because you
know we're staggering it and I think
that was something we looked out for is
like we knew hey listen we're going to
hit it hard that week one and then we
better have some place else to go you
know we better we better be able to you
know introduce the movie to other
communities and introduce the story to
other communities because I can't just
keep tweeting a hundred times a day
Sammy though it's just not it's not fair
to our Twitter stream well I felt like
okay I can do this for a week I wouldn't
want to do that to people for two months
straight you know so it's a very soon
and then the plan is still developing
we've always seen it as happening in
phases and you know phase one was let's
let's get it out to as many people as we
know you know and then es-tu is moving
out to a bigger community last night i'm
wondering do you plan to kind of coast
now a little bit more because you you've
met your goal and and the two of you are
just to the busiest people we know we
think of doers you think of enemy or
maybe where do you plan to just keep
keep steamrolling the train I mean it no
I I think it's different i don't think
it's
posting I don't think it's steamrolling
I think it's just changing areas of
focus so you know this first week was
Twitter and Facebook and our mailing
list you know this this next week has
been really about seeds denisa still not
quite available to us but steve is by
tonight and so it's really going to be
about Steve's whole um you know his old
connections and his friends and family
and people he's worked with and then
we'll probably roll into Denise you know
next week and we're also you know
starting to build just press packets so
that we can try and reach out to a more
to new communities we haven't tapped
into you know Gina is working very hard
with the cancer communities and a lot of
that is you know meeting people and
gaining their trust and letting them see
the film and know what we're all about
and that we're not just here to you know
get a quick buck and um you know and
figure out how that's going to work and
to be able to you know reach out to
those communities and so I think instead
of steam rolling over the same community
over and over and over again you know I
think we're going to give you guys a
favor i think my goal is to write some
really useful ho I hope we're really
useful blog post to find some other
gifts to give back and we're hoping that
tonight this little live chat is one of
those stuff that we can just do for the
community and I think um being able to
say the Rays obviously forty thousand
dollars and 400 backers in one week I
believe that that's a press worthy story
we told everybody that was what we
thought would happen and you know
indieWIRE picked up on it before we even
got there which was great so getting a
lot of press and I think probably
towards the end once we get close to
docu weeks we'll probably come back to
our community again and you know I just
remind everybody listen we're really
trying to follow the John Reese's plan
and you know we've done all of this with
your help and now let's get it over the
top and and I hope that the community
will accept us back after you know
several weeks away having seen the
stories and you know followed what's
going on so so that's that's kind of the
plan right now okay no let's put this in
perspective what you have done you know
let's go back to to outside the film
career studio and I guess slow me down
if I'm if I'm touching on sensitive
territory here but you won't you had
distributors look at this film ahead of
time and and and from what I remember
they weren't necessarily i'm sending you
offers that were too much higher from
where you are right now you've done this
on your own in one week hey have you had
time to reflect on that have you had
time to reflect on what you've done
biagio finger was on the email button to
send that information to the distributor
and I wasn't sure who said that she
wouldn't let me send it because they
were very honest they were very I stood
by the way by the way now even with what
we've just accomplished okay people are
still out there who don't get it who are
saying now they get their business but
we are not their business we are not
your okay I know this is a Michael Moore
documentary or I know that I can just
hit this target group and you know I
mean everyone's like you know it's a
long shot yes I know that's why we're
here you know I know you know this is
probably not international yeah I know I
get it you know you know well there's a
yeah we know don't tell me all the
things our film isn't because we know
what we need to find is someone who gets
what our film is and so that's really
where we kind of you know been like you
know let's just keep holding on to the
movie ourselves because everybody else
is giving us a very realistic and I'm
not saying they're pessimist but if our
film was just thrown into the pie I
don't think it would land right I think
that everything they're saying is
absolutely true we wouldn't be making it
wouldn't see any return on our money it
would just be one more movie that gets
right we would just be a whole ready
yeah it just would just be a movie that
got lost and so we're like okay well
then let's not throw it out there and
you know hope for a miracle let's let's
stay in charge of her own destiny and
I'm hold on to the movie and you know do
it ourselves slow rollout long roll out
whatever it's going to take you know
let's just you know what we're saying
we're going to take this movie put in
the theater near you it's not going to
be transformers where is going to be
3,000 theaters on Friday you know we're
talking about saying okay this weekend
tour in Chicago this weekend we're in
New York as weekend were in phoenix this
weekend we're in San Francisco this
weekend where you know and we're coming
with movie and Steve's going to be
performing comedy in the city
so that you know we were we're keeping
we're staying in charge of it because we
know as everyone has said to as numerous
times that if we just become part of the
machine will get swallowed up and spit
out and there won't be anything to it
yeah and so I think that in looking at
that that's why we finally said you know
what let's just do it this way let's in
wee bits an indie film indie
distribution why not I mean you know how
we feel about John in his book and the
only reason why we double doing this
what happened you keep hitting that man
I'm John spoken and we love it you know
it's hard not to enjoy it yeah so is the
plug I guess I've never even met John
I've never had a conversation with John
as always changed three weeks all I know
about judges yeah he's out of the game
seriously he talks about John's book
like was moment we wake up right before
we go to bed it's just solving the
reason we feel comfortable with this
kind of self distribution model i guess
that we're kind of figuring out as we go
ah is because of the responses that
we've gotten from audiences you know
these standing ovations you sold out
crowds everybody's staying for the full
Q&A you know if we weren't getting that
kind of response we wouldn't be spending
this much time energy and money into it
either you know he'd be like okay well
you know it's it's all right it's it's
it's an average thing and let's go get
an average response somewhere but
because we've gotten such a positive
response when we actually showed a film
and then you talk to the machine which
I'm calling them now and there's nothing
wrong with the mushy mushy I a machine
if you want to distribute our movie in a
big way we're here for you don't worry
about it but we need somebody within the
machine who gets how we're different and
how do we use the machine to help the
movie and so far we haven't found that
so right now we're just kind of working
on the outside and that's fine you know
again like I all respect toward the
machine and hopefully I'll make my own
you know Armageddon one day and you know
we'll be part of the machine and it will
blow up but you know I think at this
point you know we have to do what's
right for each project and this project
right now needs this kind of TLC to to
make it yeah I'm not gonna lie we get it
most distributors is your documentaries
I mean think about it there are their
business to make money we all they have
to be or you go bro be end up destitute
so they
their markets that they market a movie
too and the and I think it's a
compliment everybody keeps telling us
the problem with your movie is it just
has too much broad appeal so it's it's
it's so what you need to really make
this movie work is you need a big huge
release and we can't do that for you and
I get that because they can't just go
and sell this to one or two communities
so it's like I feel like it's either
going to be like a dream works or a
universe or somebody comes along and
it's like we're gonna make the supersize
me or else the only way it's going to
have the life who thinks it deserved is
if we make sure that happens and so you
know and by the way less on the
grassroots level on the grassroots level
I don't think there's anything wrong
with that I love working on the
grassroots level you know every film
festival we go to we get out there and
it's it's art it's our honor to go out
in the line before the movie starts
shake everybody's hand thank them for
coming to our movie thank them for
spending their hard-earned cash and
seeing our movie and let them know how
much we appreciate their there and
that's not an act that's not something
we do that's something like I grew up
working it as a dishwasher delivering
pizzas you know bagging groceries like I
have worked every you know every crappy
job along the way I possibly can I know
what that money's worth them and it
means a lot to me that they spend our
ten dollars to come see our movie and we
will always be that grateful i'll never
forget that you know and i like being
out there to think I mean you wouldn't
any other business why not this one at
the heart of all of this this is all for
Steve and it's all for Denise I mean can
you put into words what this means to
the two of them oh my god you're gonna
make me cry again no I think I listen I
think you know it's something that we
it's that hard line the walk because we
all know that Steve he has a disease
accenture you know he has something that
they can't be treated he needs them to
find a cure for cancer or he just needs
to be locked and so far he's been lucky
you know I mean he's outlived his worst
case diagnosis some people who had been
diagnosed the same time as him have
passed away someone passed away you know
on our second screening that day someone
that we knew that we invent it was this
really wonderful woman that was young
and full of life younger than us ahem
from the same kind of cancer seed has
and so I think that Steve knows now that
his legacy is in place like I think he
knows that his family and his kids and
free
is not even see now i'm going to you you
guys know I'm emotional you know if you
ask the question you're gonna get me I
don't let me update 13 is that it lucky
update number 13 that's the one that's
the one we were both if you go to
Kickstarter page an update 13 um that's
when we just broke broke the goal and we
called Steve on the phone to tell him on
camera oh goody a bushel um it was it
was amazing and I have set from the very
everything changed for me on opening
night when we showed the film at
cinequest and we filled a whole theater
and everybody stood up at standing
ovation to Steve and he stood there and
he took it all in and I told biagio that
night I said I don't think we will ever
be able to give anyone a gift like this
ever again and so um to hear him so
excited and so thankful to be on this
journey that's just really um you know
you did it error um but that's you know
we're starting to cry this is the joke
and Biagio film current moment here yeah
it's just you know it makes it all worth
it and that's why we didn't even know
what our he was going to get on we're in
the middle of all of shooting you know
we always looked at each other and you
know sometimes it was hard and you know
we didn't have money and it's just like
what are we doing and it was like at the
end of the day we knew that we would
have we were we would be able to leave
something for his family and his friends
and hopefully these kids to remember him
by and I'm at the end of the day that's
what it was always about yeah and I
think he feels that way you know we were
gonna ask you you know convince us to
back this campaign I don't even think
it's appropriate to ask that I I get it
we're gonna we're going to ask anyone
who watches this video go go to their
Kickstarter page go go to their
Kickstarter update number 13 watch that
video and I guess that will speak for
itself but but but anyone that wants to
contribute to the campaign how do they
do so how do they get behind this it's
so it's so easy um you can just go to
dying to do Letterman calm forward slash
fund f UND deine 11.com ford / fund and
that automatically redirects to our
kickstarter page if you forget the
forward slash part just go to dinah do
Letterman
and click on the giant green button that
says help us win an Oscar so it's pretty
easy we made it as simple as we could
and we would love to have any of you
that they can pledge and you know and
help us like chase this dream of of
using Kickstarter to put a movie in
theaters of trying this new model and
bringing Steve's story to theaters and
letting him enjoy every single day he
has left in the spotlight letting him
travel and perform stand-up comedy and
common do Q&A after the movies we would
love to have your support we would love
to have you there so come and give at
least a dollar and would love to have
and 10,000 if you can afford thank you
so what lessons have you learned from
from all of this that you just didn't
expect I I'm ten minutes late for
another so she said she already said she
did she's gonna run out I will take the
last question and I'll jump into the
meeting with her we're gonna wrap up
with just a minute thank you for staying
with us oh they are you kidding me
outside she's way prettier than me and
the picture probably degrades when she
steps away but but i would i would say
listen here are the lessons we learned
when everyone tells you your movie
doesn't have a chance if you believe in
that and you believe in it screw them
make your movie number two if you give
to the community i really believe this
community gives back to you um number
three I would say that you know passion
uh passion needs to be the deciding
factor in every project you do you know
I would we wrote this recently and lift
the movie you're going to make doesn't
keep you up late at night if it doesn't
bounce you out of bed in the morning if
it's not something that you know makes
you laugh or cry or get emotional just
thinking about making it don't make it
go make another movie it's way too hard
it's way too difficult to to spend all
your life and spare moments and
resources and a project that doesn't
just absolutely make you giddy about
making it so I think those are those are
the three big things we've learned i
think from that from the campaign
overall and as we wrap up one of the
sort of tag lines of your campaign is
that dreams do matter to kid you can you
share with us on why dreams matter from
from the person from a personal
perspective
yeah I think that um my belief and a lot
of people disagree with this but I
believe that the world would be a much
better place if we all chased our dreams
doesn't matter if we achieve it or not I
think that chasing a dream makes you a
better person I think the chasing a
dream you know gives you the energy and
the you know the the ability to enjoy
life more to to learn more to take it to
take every experience that you have in
life through a different filter when
things are hard and you're not chasing
your dream life sucks when things are
hard and you're chasing your dream
you're just learning lessons and getting
better and I you know listen I love you
know I'm so glad there's so many big
policy documentaries I think they're
very important I think they have to be
made I think one thing about Doc's is
they do and can change the world and I I
think that in our small way our doc is
saying we can change the world if we all
just chase our dreams whatever that
dream is um so I I do i think i think
that if we all chase the dream even if
it's impossible even if you never think
you'll make it i think in the end you'll
be a better person you know should they
have to say shoot for the moon and even
if you miss you'll land among the stars
and i believe that i really do that's
great thank you that's beautiful yeah I
mean there we have it the sort of brings
us to an end here my feeling is that
this conversation that we just had is is
probably just I mean how it since
literally one of the the most moving
most inspiring most informative
conversations that we've had to date I
think out of everything we've ever done
and then I can't imagine if your
crowdfunding I can't imagine you not
watch watching this from start to finish
we want to thank you beyond you want to
thank job for sitting in this has been
just an absolute just invigorating
starts who are day yeah well thank you i
can't say enough good things about film
courage about your show about what you
do for the community guys you're sitting
here watching his don't forget they
discovered us film courage put us all
yeah and I meant with this community
with this community you guys did and we
thank you
but but really you put in so much equity
both un joke and really it shows it's
paying off I mean it just just what
you've given back is really coming back
to you tenfold and and I think that's an
a lesson in all of this as well so yeah
thank you we appreciate it all right and
both love you kisses for me and joke and
thank you guys so much you really
appreciate it absolutely absolutely you
thank you thank you thank you thank your
goodbyes all right